in order to get in front of a venture
capitalist you need an introduction
believe it or not venture capitalists
don't want to meet people just because
they have great ideas there's a million
ideas out there the difference between
an inventor and an entrepreneur is an
inventor comes up with an idea an
entrepreneur is able to take the idea
and turn that into an opportunity a big
part of what you have to do is an
entrepreneur in addition to finding
product market fit which i think is the
most important thing is you have to sell
a lot of different constituencies you
have to convince people to give you
money you have to convince people to
join you in the company you have to
convince customers to buy your product
and cold calls don't work on any of
those so the reason that the venture
capitalists only want to meet with
people who are introduced is it's sort
of a test if you can't get an
introduction into them then you're
unlikely to succeed in selling the other
constituencies
you